[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 7-8 week-end voici les titres de
ce vendredi 23 avril le premier ministre
jean castex a fait un point d'étape sur
la crise sanitaire lors d'une conférence
de presse jeudi 22 avril est la rentrée
scolaire est confirmée au 26 avril mais
pas de calendrier précis pour la
réouverture des commerces et des lieux
culturels le flou demeure pour réagir
nos invités lionel masse et à directeur
du théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et romain gicquel chef du restaurant la
ferme de voisins également pour soulager
les hôpitaux sous pression avec la crise
sanitaire des lits ont été
réquisitionnés dans les cliniques de
soins pour être transformés en ligne
médicalisé exemple à guyancourt à la
clinique clos korian le grand parc
enfin comme chaque semaine et même
confiné célia agathe son go vous
proposera ses idées sorties et loisirs m
et nous l'avons appris vendredi une
fonctionnaire de police de 49 ans du
commissariat de rambouillet a été
assassiné elle s'est fait poignarder
dans le sas d'entrée du commissariat
l'assaillant a été abattu par ses
collègues les fonctionnaires de police
le premier ministre jean castex le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
tout comme le préfet des yvelines se
sont rendus sur place également la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse pécresse était aussi
sur place
nous vous donnerons plus d'informations
dans nos prochaines éditions et sur nos
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
comme je vous le disais en titre le
premier ministre s'est exprimé jeudi
soir pour faire un nouveau point d'étape
sur la crise sanitaire
un discours attendu sur le déconfinement
progressif mais des points restent
toujours à éclaircir
d'abord la rentrée en présentiel pour
les écoles maternelles et primaires a
été confirmée par jean castex pour ce
lundi 26 avril
tout comme celles des collèges et lycées
une semaine plus tard le lundi 3 mai
avec un protocole renforcé dès qu'un cas
de co vide sera détecté la classe sera
fermée tous les élèves considérés comme
cas contactez davantage de tests
salivaires seront déployés dans les
écoles élémentaires et pour les lycées
c'est l'auto test qui va être généralisé
avec un test par semaine et par élève
d'ores et déjà le syndicat fsu 78 a
déposé un préavis de grève qui court du
lundi 26 au vendredi 30 avril prochain
le syndicat n'est pas satisfaits du
protocole annoncé par le gouvernement en
ce qui concerne les autres annonces sur
lesquelles le premier ministre était
attendu pas encore de calendrier précis
de réouverture pour les lieux dits non
essentiels la mi mai est toujours
envisagée comme deuxième étape du
déconfinement progressif mais pour le
moment commerces bars restaurants ou
encore lieux culturels sont toujours
dans le flou le premier ministre a
également annoncé que le couvre-feu fixé
à 19 heures aujourd'hui et est maintenue
jusqu'à nouvel ordre pour réagir à cette
nouvelle prise de parole du premier
ministre nous accueillons en
visioconférence avec nous romain gicquel
bonsoir vous êtes chef du restaurant la
ferme de voisins à voisins le bretonneux
avec nous également lyonnais de masse et
à directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir
comme je disais le flou demeure pour vos
deux secteurs la restauration mais aussi
la culture d'abord lyonnais de masse et
à est-ce que vous vous attendiez à avoir
une date de réouverture lors de cette
conférence de presse de ce jeudi 22
avril
bah on en a eu des annonces
enfin le secteur culturel et de la même
façon avec des annonces
sur deux des délais qui ont été données
mais qui sont hypothétiques après nous
ne sommes pas totalement déconnectés de
la vie réelle et on regarde également
les chiffres l'évolution de l'épidémie
de la pandémie
donc effectivement je crois que c'est ça
qui va décider
mais on s'attendait pas non je dois dire
voilà aujourd'hui on regarde les
chiffres de façon assez lucide et assez
concrète voilà tout simplement et je
crois qu'on a ses habitués à ces à ces
nouvelles lois pour ne pas en attendre
de ses points de presse
voilà des des nouvelles très précises en
tout cas pas pour l'instant mais il ya
des intentions de sorte de droit romain
gicquel lorsque vous avez entendu du
coup que vous n'aurez pas de date
précise pas de calendrier ce jeudi soir
quelle a été votre réaction en tant que
restaurateur lyonnais savent pas du
s'attendait pas content surprise bon bah
ça a été le cas on n'a toujours pas de
plan devait y est ça commence à faire
très très long on aimerait bien un peu
et quelques signaux positifs
on est un petit peu plus de grain à
moudre parce que effectivement elle
comprenait au moins qu'on s'organise et
là on est toujours dans le flou et a
commencé justement en parlant
d'organisation jean castex n'a donc pas
de les cadrer précis je le rappelle il a
tout de même évoqué envisager ces mots
la mi mai pour une réouverture partielle
notamment des terrasses en ce qui
concerne les bars et restaurants mais
pour la culture
pas vraiment de piste pour le moment
comment on anticipe lionel masse et à
quand on est directeur d'un théâtre
comme vous et que l'on sait que la
programmation d'un spectacle ne peut pas
se faire du jour au lendemain j'avais en
a passé quasiment un an essayer
d'anticiper systématiquement
c'est-à-dire à organiser une réouverture
possible probable hypothétique
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a à paris
entre chose c'est une réactivité totale
c'est à dire que si on a une réponse sur
une date de réouverture une semaine
avant je pense qu'on sera tous parés à
rouvrir parallèlement
le théâtre est loin d'être d'être
inactif puisque on a sans cesse de
l'habitation là on a des répétitions 30
pendant quinze jours on a eu un certain
nombre d'adaptations et on est prêt à
continuer comme ça bien entendu on a
envie de revoir le public on a envie de
reprendre programmation normale mais
aujourd'hui on est extrêmement réactive
en fonction des annonces ou des noms
annonce romain gicquel cela fait plus
d'un an que nous c'est que nous sommes
pardon dans cette situation de crise
sanitaire
une grande partie de ses plus d'un an
vous avez été fermé en tant que
restaurant
est-ce que rouvrir uniquement les
terrasses ou bien en demies jauge à
l'intérieur comme on a pu entendre dans
votre établissement
est-ce que c'est intéressant
financièrement pour vous intéresse en
plus infirme en ont mais on a besoin
d'eux on a besoin de quelque chose de
positif on a besoin de repartir
beaucoup d'entre nous n'ont pas de
terrasse malheureusement beaucoup
d'autres au nom d'on si le temps est au
rendez vous si le temps est au rendez
vous cela pourrait nous être un petit
peu utile et au moins nous aider à
relancer la machine à faire à voir venir
les avec les équipes r démarrer un petit
peu quoi
maintenant on est content il bien que on
va être que mois de mai et que le temps
sera peut-être pas de la partie et s'il
est pas de la partie ça va être
compliqué parce que rentrée de la
marchandise pour panne avant
d'intervenir les gares les paires bosser
mais l'envié pâtit de la perte ya un
mois on a vu que mes valises des
économies de pied là et on ne fera pas
le coup vous vous attendez du coup vous
l'avez tout à l'heure au magic est là
justement d'être prévenus on va dire 48
heures sont douze heures avant la
possible réouverture
comment anticipez-vous aussi en tant qu
en tant que restaurateurs sur les stocks
sur le personnel qui est j'imagine en
partie en chômage partiel
alors on a l'habitude hyper réactif dans
notre métier donc on l'est encore et
encore plus que d'habitude on a la
chance d'avoir relancé du click and
collect depuis le début l'année donc ce
qui nous permet d'avoir les équipes sur
site d'avoir relancé l'équipe d'avoir
remis un peu le nom de travail nous
avons un métier métier c'est la mémoire
du geste il faut que les gars viennent
bosser et gallery un pardon mais que les
équipes viennent bosser pour se
réapproprier de leur graisse leur
technique et érodé la machine a loué le
travail 6 7 mois
et pour reprendre les habitudes c'est
pas facile alors on sera prêt nous vous
avez les restaurateurs on a beau dire ce
qu'on veut bien sûr nous a prévenus à
l'avancé
et si demain le vert on est dans les
stars alors on parle de déconfinement
progressif de possible réouverture à la
mi-mai en tout cas c'est envisagé par le
gouvernement je le rappelle une question
une dernière question pour tous les deux
peut-être le lma s'était d'abord avez
vous des craintes si on anticipe eu
vraiment encore plus de refermeture on
va dire ça comme ça avant après l'été je
suis tout à l'heure lassé d'être d'être
du site de regarder les chiffres des
spécialistes lecture des chiffres qui
ont presque les avancées du gouvernement
on n'est pas à l'abri de ça on leur là
la question qu'on m'a posé une question
à laquelle personne absolument personne
ne corresponde à ce jour si on pouvait
répondre à cette question est ce qu'on
va rouvrir refermer je pense qu'on voit
là les burdisso est déjà derrière
aujourd'hui on parle sur du tu dis moi
de vous dire ça mais on parle sur des à
partir de donneurs ne connais absolument
pas partir d'évolution de la maladie
connaît absolument pas donc je pense que
ce soit les des lieux culturels les
restaurants endroit tout simplement
soumis à cette temporairement non par
une autre entité là pardon et à cette
évolution de la pandémie
donc aujourd'hui on se soumet à ça on
accepte cette chose là même si c'est
très compliqué et pour les yeux et pour
le personnel et pour les abris pour les
publics
je le rappelle ici parce qu'on a pas
parlé depuis le début de cette interview
mais voilà on se soumettra aux décisions
qui sont prises on n'oubliera pas eu
[Musique]
c'est ainsi on est on est tout
simplement réaliste et fatalistes et
voulant sûr que le gouvernement qui
décide évidemment la crise sanitaire
évoluant suit son évolution
rominger qu'elle est quand même la même
question avez vous des craintes de
refermeture de votre restera à la fin de
l'été puisque ça s'est passé comme ça
finalement il l'année dernière on a vu
cette situation c'est pour ça d'où ma
question on a vu ce confinement ce
déconfinement puis se re confinant et
cette fermeture qui qui dure un peu
maintenant vous avez
est obligé de fermer le restaurant
personne ne vous aurais cru à ce moment
là déjà permet une deuxième fois c'était
compliqué mais il fallait pas être dupe
non plus on a vu comment s'est passé
l'été on a vu la réouverture j'ai vu
venir maladies évitables
il serait bien qu'on fasse le nécessaire
pour éviter un troisième confinement ou
troisième fermeture
maintenant on ne maîtrise pas du tout
les chiffres cette contrainte en méconnu
si vous fermez on fermera mais il ya un
moment il faut peut-être aussi commencé
à vivre avec et réussir à s'adapter
parce qu'on ne va pas cristallisées
l'activité de je ne sais combien le
métier depuis je ne sais combien de
travail de salariés et d'employeurs de
gens qui ont envie parce que ce sont
beaucoup de métier de passion qui sont
bloqués en ce moment et quand on est
passionné par ce métier on a envie
d'aller bosser quand on apprend les
ghosts à la maison ou au chômage partiel
va chômage partiel si une question le le
vide de lien social quand même d'aller
au boulot et on le comprend bien merci à
tous les deux lionel masse et à romain
gicquel d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
7,8 week end et si l'on parle de
déconfinement progressif à la proche de
l'été la pression sur les hôpitaux elle
est toujours aussi forte avec la crise
sanitaire
alors pour les soulager les cliniques de
soins de suite ont été réquisitionnés
exemple à la clinique korian le grand
parc de guyancourt reportage de célia
gars de son gauche 36 lits transformer
en lits de médecine le troisième étage
de la clinique korian le grand parc de
guyancourt qui est normalement consacré
aux soins de suite et réadaptation est
réservé depuis quelques mois aux
patients qu'aux vite plus et aux
patients non qu'ovide mais qui ont
besoin de plus de soins il faut imaginer
que dans un étage de médecine il faut
doubler les effectifs que l'on a en
temps normal dans un soins de suite et
de réadaptation
il a fallu trouver des médecins des
infirmiers des aides soignants et il a
fallu investir également dans du
matériel qu'on a pas peut-être en temps
normal
électrocardiogramme celle agences
régionales de santé qui a demandé à tous
les établissements de soins de suite de
la région de créer des lits de médecine
pour prendre en charge des patients le
but désengorger les hôpitaux du
département voire de la région
c'est toute une réorganisation pour les
médecins de cette clinique qui ne
pratiquaient pas ce genre de soins avant
ses services c'est ce qu'on a mis en
place en c'est un service qui accueille
des patients au sortir d'une phase aiguë
qui ne sont pas encore stabilisés donc
qu'ils peuvent des compensées qui ont
besoin d'un ratio plus important de
soignants et de médecins parce qu'il ya
plus de surveillance cette patiente a
été hospitalisé à l'hôpital de mignot de
versailles pour une fracture ouverte de
la hanche déclaré par la suite qu vie de
plus elle a donc été transféré à la
clinique de guyancourt le transfert
s'est fait par ambulance
mais non c'est arrivé ici on image été
arrêté à l'entrée on savait exactement
ce que j'avais et on m'a aiguillé tout
de suite vers une chambre isolée pour
terminer mon confinement les patients
hospitalisés ici reste entre une et deux
semaines
cette patiente qui avait une fracture à
la hanche peut bénéficier donc
maintenant des soins de suite et
réadaptation la spécialité initial de la
clinique le grand parc de guyancourt
après une semaine bien chargée et quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week-end
même pendant le confinement célia gars
tsongo vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
cette semaine nous allons vous emmener
pêcher à la pisciculture de ville est un
lieu idéal pour apprendre la
pisciculture de villette à plusieurs
bassins est temps pour débutants et
confirmés l'occasion d'une sortie en
famille avec bixente moeurs entité ban
nous nous sommes initiés à la pêche
[Musique]
nous sommes deux à la pisciculture des
villes est en compagnie d'emmanuel aux
copains bonjour bonjour et bienvenu
merci vous êtes le responsable donc de
la pisciculture
alors vous vous maintenez de me donner
une canne à pêche
il ya un saut aider à passer ça
exactement
moi je n'ai jamais pêché est-ce que
c'est compliqué c'est pas très compliqué
à la pisciculture du villette en
accueille de nombreux pêcheurs adultes
ou même enfants à partir de 3 ans qui
viennent découvrir la pêche
alors je vous ai confié une petite et la
pêche très simple équipé d'un fils d'un
bouchon orange et au bout d'un petit
hameçon cette absence et le crochet qui
va attraper le poisson pour commencer on
décroche l'âme seront dans ce petit pot
vers il ya de la pâte à pain il faut
donc former des petites boules pour
faire des appâts et c'est parti le
bouchon orange doit être sur l'eau et
quand le bouchon cool il faut ferrer
c'est à dire tirer vers le haut d'un
coup sec et bravo et voilà et là on a
donc une truite arc en ciel donc c'est
une truite qui est âgé d'à peu près 12
13 mois elle fait 300 grammes elle a des
belles nageoires bien développé ça fait
quinze minutes que je suis en train de
pêcher
alors au début c'est vrai que c'est
assez compliqué hein faut prendre le
coup de main et puis finalement j'ai
péché de trois poissons
voilà c'est déjà pas mal c'est super
c'est un très bon début
la pisciculture et l'art d'élever les
poissons à la villette ce sont
essentiellement les truites arc en ciel
les truites fario et des saumons de
fontaine
là vous avez donc des bassins pour le
plus tôt les débutants mais finalement
il ya des bassins pour plusieurs niveaux
des rythmes parce que arrivé à un moment
ça va trop vite ici donc on a un un lac
qui est juste derrière à une dizaine de
mètres d'ici ou là les gens viennent
avec leur propre matériel puis six
équipes après même des enfants et ils
passent la demi journée ou la journée au
bord de l'eau alors là c'est la vraie
pêche ça mord pas instantanément faut
parfois attendre une demi-heure avant
qu'ils aient une truc qui manque par
contre c'est plus fin on va changer la
part va avoir un film beaucoup plus fin
que celui là mais trois poissons pêchés
je me dirige en boutique pour les faire
vider ce magasin vend des produits du
terroir mais aussi détruite ou saumon
fumé des terrines et rillettes de
poisson donc voilà vos poissons et les
fiches recettes qui vont avec hubert
labrie dégustation merci voilà moi je
repars avec eux mais trois poissons j'en
ai eu pour 9 euros pêche et poissons
compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une idée de visite à présent le château
de rambouillet est fermée pour cause de
crise sanitaire
alors pour continuer à le faire vivre le
des visites en extérieur sont proposés
astrid bergère est allé faire un tour à
la règle w ira véritable château fort
une heure pour parcourir 500 ans
d'histoire
le château de rambouillet propose des
visites chaque vendredi à 11h et 15h en
extérieur dans les jardins avec une
jauge réduite 5 personnes maximum et
masque obligatoire
ce jour-là une mère et ses deux enfants
sont venus admirer les extérieurs
notamment les temps ça fait un moment
qu'on n'a pas eu l'occasion de faire des
visites guidées et là l'occasion s'est
présentée on a sauté dessus parce qu'il
aime beaucoup les châteaux et c'était
l'occasion de faire quelque chose
pendant les vacances avec l'eau qu'est
ce que tu as pensé cette visite très
bien qu'est ce que tu as aimé
surtout les explications des rois à
travers les jardins et les façades du
château la visite retrace les
différentes époques de l'histoire de
l'édifice et les grands personnages qui
y sont passés de moeurs princières et
royales résidence dampier ensuite
présidentielle un an qu'un c'est très
riche en histoire en histoire de france
la réservation se fait uniquement sur
les sites internet du château prochaine
visite vendredi 30 avril à 15h le
créneau de 11h affiche déjà complet
la fête de la librairie c'est ce samedi
24 avril plus de 480 libraires en france
en belgique et au luxembourg soutiennent
l'événement à saint quentin en yvelines
deux librairies participent à
l'opération
leur hangar un bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le responsable de la librairie le pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux et
michel fourré le bon soir vous êtes
gérant de la librairie
le pavé de l'âme de l'homme dans la mare
à elancourt alors une première question
pour vous cela fait plus de quinze ans
que vous participez du cou à cette
opération
comment vous allez célébrer cette fête
ce samedi
déjà on va remettre ce petit fascicule
on a aussi mis donc à nos atouts nos
clients lecteurs
et puis ça va leur rappeler un petit peu
la mission de la librairie indépendante
qui pour moi est quand même importante
et c'est surtout un engagement c'est
plutôt travailler dans une librairie
indépendante c'est s'engager c'est
s'engager pour offrir une diversité dans
une offre culturelle c'est s'engager
pour des écrivains c'est s'engager pour
des textes et puis les faire parvenir
aux lecteurs vers la librairie
indépendante se nourrit de tout de tout
cela quoi donc
le fait qu'ils aient seul une journée
consacrée à la librairie indépendante et
bien je trouve ça très bien ce samedi 24
avril c'est aussi les 40 ans de la loi
lang qui encadrent le prix du livre
laurent garou qu'est ce que cette loi
apporte une allemand aux librairies
indépendantes
alors elle apporte énormément de
diversité un fort maillage en france en
fait sa loi nous a permis de conserver
un pôle unique fixé par l'éditeur
ce qui fait que ça permet d'avoir une
diversité éditoriale qui qui n'est pas
contraint par le crif
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut
accuser de poésie chilienne on peut
avoir des sciences humaines très pointu
avoir très peu d'exemplaires et ça nous
permet donc de faire vivre toutes ces
petites maisons d'édition et toutes nos
petites librairies indépendantes tout
autour dans la transe et cette loi donc
a vraiment permis que on et diversité en
fort panel de
donc couleurs au niveau de l'édition
française est ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aura plus de monde ce samedi dans votre
livre avec les librairies
grâce à 7,7 oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est
important que les gens sont vraiment
attachés on nous offre à saper
maintenant ce moment là que les gens
nous le prouvent qu'ils sont attachés à
la librairie indépendante en france donc
il ya un fort engouement derrière la
lecture est derrière les commerces
locaux et la librairie indépendante donc
oui je pense que forcément on va y avoir
plus de monde que d'habitude
michel fourel la crise sanitaire a
ébranlé le secteur de la culture
est ce que les clients sont quand même
toujours au rendez vous dans vos livres
votre librairie ne va plus que jamais
oui tout à fait je crois que le temps
dont il dispose
fait que le consacre beaucoup à la
lecture et ça touche tout l'étrange
toutes les tranches d'âge
donc c'est avec très un très grand
plaisir que voilà que nous nous recevons
énormément de clients tous les jours
c'est fort agréable de devoir que la
librairie à dire l'image de la librairie
indépendante soit remis au goût du jour
et et je leur en gardant la question
qu'est ce que vous attendez finalement
de cette fête
ben partage c'est d'habitude on est là
pour échanger avec les gens voilà donc
tous nous ont fait passer des livres on
peut passer des idées des auteurs mais
on prend aussi beaucoup
donc c'est un vrai échange qui a
toujours lieu c'est une vraie rencontre
entre les électeurs et nous mêmes donc
voilà ça va être un moment convivial
parce qu'on va pouvoir parler un peu de
la loi lang parce que ça cette loi est
un peu méconnu du grand public donc
reparler de cette importance dans ses 40
ans de cette loi donc voilà on va
discuter autour de livrer aussi autour
de l'importance de la librairie
indépendante française
eh bien merci beaucoup laurent garin et
michel fraile d'avoir été invité merci
ça vient
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une activité deux sorties pour
ce week end un tournoi de jeux vidéo en
ligne sera organisée samedi 24 avril de
16h à 21h par la ville des mureaux et l'
entreprise d'événementiel even to give
le lm xo gaming challenge sera diffusée
en direct sur les réseaux sociaux de la
ville des mureaux le jeu choisi
roquettes ligue 64 équipes
s'affronteront de nombreux lots sont à
gagner et le cpie ce week-end de
continuer avec lots nord pour parler de
l'actualité
vous
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est mélanie
poker qui vous la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
la vaccination bat son plein au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
cinquante mille personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées le président du sénat gérard
larcher a fait le point que les élus
beaucoup sans grands groupes pour penser
les solutions et les services de
mobilité de demain dans son coin
république sera installée dans le
bâtiment odyssey du technocentre renault
de guyancourt un bilan sans surprise la
fréquentation touristique dans les
yvelines a été profondément touché par
la crise sanitaire de la coved 19
hôtelier sites touristiques ou vu
baisser leur fréquentation de plus de
50%
trois nouvelles navettes de transport à
la demande s'ajoute aux trois déjà
existantes au sein de l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire depuis janvier
le but de ce transport permettre à des
personnes des zones rurales d'accéder
aux centres des grandes villes du
territoire une solution d'urgence
composé par le département deux éleveurs
se sont établis au haras des bréviaires
ils ne peuvent pas s'installer à un
dainville sur fond de bataille juridique
un triste record plus de cent mille
personnes sont décédées de la commune de
francs france un traumatisme pour les
familles qui ont perdu un proche et qui
n'ont pas pu leur dire au revoir
[Musique]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez-vous en partenariat avec les
surligneurs on écoute vincent couronne
docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs
coup de théâtre sur coup de théâtre dans
le monde du football européen
dimanche soir une coalition de 12 des
plus grands clubs européens annoncent la
création d'une super ligue semi fermée
autant dire sans vraiment de compétition
de toute façon cette annonce qui a fait
l'effet d'une bombe n'est plus vraiment
d'actualité puisque le projet a été vite
suspendu une suspension qui est due
essentiellement à la pression politique
et populaire
le vice président de la commission
européenne margaritis chine as la
considère comme étant incompatible avec
le mode de vie des européens
et c'est sans oublier les fédérations
l'uefa et la fifa qui ont réagi en
menaçant les clubs rebelles de leur
interdire l'accès au mondial ou encore à
l'euro
sauf que ces menaces avaient peu de
chances d'être mise à exécution dès
mardi un tribunal espagnol a ordonné à
l'uefa et à la fifa de ne prendre aucune
sanction disciplinaire à l'encontre des
clubs de l'éphémère super league
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il ya un
précédent en 2017 la commission
européenne avait sanctionné l'union
internationale de patinage pour avoir
pris le même type de sanctions à l'égard
des patineurs qui allait concourir dans
les compétitions qu'elle n'avait pas
elle même reconnu la raison est simple
de telles sanctions réduisent la
compétition certes sportive mais surtout
économique ce qu'on appelle la
concurrence l'uefa et la fifa aurait
donc été dans l'illégalité
mais on peut aussi considérer que la
super league pourquoi pas aussi aurait
très bien pu être dans l'illégalité
parce que puisqu'on parle de concurrence
prenez les 12 plus grands clubs de foot
qui s'entendent entre eux pour se garder
la part du lion des droits tv au
détriment des plus petits clubs
c'est ce qu'on pourrait peut-être
appeler une entente anticoncurrentielle
autrement dit un cartel du foot et ça
serait potentiellement interdite par les
règles européennes de concurrence
jeudi potentiellement car nous n'en
savons rien puisque la super league est
suspendu pour le plus grand bonheur des
supporteurs européen qui n'aime rien
moins qu'une vraie compétition
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée un bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]